その時はこの戒律のことは関係ないんです
関係ないけど 戒律はある人が瞑想するんだからね
それは基本的な条件で
瞑想というその行為には戒律ということは関係なくなっちゃうんです
もう何もしないことだからね
戒律の場合は ですから
それは基礎的な条件になってしまって
そういう心は生まれません
普通の善心の場合 善心ではこの三つは別々に生まれるんです
ある時だけ それだけ それから出てくるのはアッパマンニャというカルナ・ムディタなんですね
で 慈悲喜捨の慈と捨が
なんでないんだか そういうのはちょっと私はまあ
考えなくちゃいけないんだけど
カルナ 慈の慈はアドーサとして不信として入ってるんだと
いわゆる怒りがない いわゆる十九の共一切身所あります
その中にアドーサ入ってます
不信が入ってます 不信が入っている場合は怒り
不信ですか 怒りがない
不信が入って 怒りがないだけのことなんですけど
その上 慈しみの心が生まれると
同じ心所が成長するということにしてるんです
普通にいい行動をしていると
もう怒りがない 普通ないい行動をしている時は
いわゆる普通の善心の場合は怒りがない
だからって慈悲あるわけでもないんです
そこで慈悲がある時は
この怒りのないという不信の心所が慈しみに成り代わる
というアビダンマの定義であって
違うではないかで言ったっても構いません
慈悲の感情が別な感情ではないかと思っても
別にどうってことないと思います
それでウペッカーはね
捨はどこに入ったかというと
タットラマッジャッタタという十九種類の心所の中に一つあったんですね
中捨という心所がありますね
その中捨という心所はこのウペッカーを瞑想すると大きくなっていくんだということなんです
そうすると残るのはカルナとムディタなんですね
メッタ・ウペッカーはもうなくなっ
共一切身所に入ってるんです
メッタとウペッカー だから
これとこれが共一切身所に入っている
でもメッターとして入ってるわけじゃない
メッターの瞑想をすると共一切身所の一部が成長する
ウペッカーを瞑想すると捨を瞑想すると中捨という心所が成長する
で カルナ・ムディタの二つは別に成長しなくちゃいけない心所なんです
カルナの場合は罰苦ですか
人の苦しみ 人の悩みを何とかしてあげたくなると
だから衆生の苦しみを見る
衆生の苦しみを見たところで放っておけない
何とかしたいなという生まれる気持ちがカルナなんですね
ムディタの場合は衆生の幸福を見る
幸福を見て ああ良かったんではないかと喜びが生まれてくる
すごく楽しくなる みんな幸せでよかった
で それはもう嫉妬の反対の心所なんです
人の幸福を見ると 普通だったら嫉妬する
怒りが生まれる 嫉妬する
仏教では人が幸福だったら嫉妬するんじゃなくて喜べと
楽しめと だから嫉妬するのはバカバカらしいんです
例えば 自分より美しい人がいる
自分より知識がある人がいる
自分より体力がある人より自分より若い人がいる
そういう他人が何か自分より何か持っている
それに嫉妬すると ものすごいもうバカバカらしい無知そのものなんです
自分には何の関係もないのに
それに嫉妬して なんでこちらが罪を犯さなくちゃいけないんですかね
隣の人がものすごい勉強できて頭がいいんだと
そうすると こちらの人がどんどんどんどん罪を犯して地獄に落ちるんだと
バカバカらしいんです
隣の人には宝くじが当たりました
そこでこちらの家族がそれで地獄に落ちるんだと
どういうことですかと
あれでもうね 知識人だと言えますかね
ですから 嫉妬っていうのはあまりにもバカだからしいんです
だからもうどうしても無知はずっと不善心にあるんだと
無知だからもうそんなことをするんだと
隣の人に宝くじが当たったら
あ よかった 隣の人に当たったよと自分も喜べば
自分がそれで楽しいし
で 何のことなく自分に幸福感を味わえるんですね
ですから 人の能力 才能を見て喜びなさいというのは仏教の言葉なんです
エゴがあるとできないんで
エゴが働いていると なんで俺にないかということになっちゃうんだから
ですから 人の才能やら能力やらね
幸福を見てみれば見る
あーよかったよかったよかった
と楽しめばいいんです
幸福を味わえばいいんです
喜び味わえば 生命っていうのは喜びを楽しみを味わいたいでしょうに
それが善神なんです すごく喜びにあふれて
楽しみで心があふれて幸せでいることが生命願っていることです
明るくなりたいな どうすればいいかわからない
そんなくだらないことを言うんじゃなくて
明るくなりたければいくらでもあるでしょうに
情報は 自分の頭が悪くたっても頭の人々は腐るほどいるんだから
それを見て ああ みんな頭が良かった
良かったと 私の頭が悪くたっても大丈夫だと
頭のいい人はいっぱいいるんだから
で まあ日本でどうかわかりませんだけど
僕らはこの子供たちに教えたりすると
このクラスの中でいろんな才能ある子供たちがいるんですね
それで教えてる側としては
まあ一人の子は全部才能を持ってるわけじゃないんだけど
それバラバラですからね
全部楽しいんですね このクラスのこの子は歌がうまいんだと
この子喋るのはすごい上手だと
この子は他の他のことはすごい上手で
この子はこの子はものすごい作文がすごい上手に書くんだと
この子は覚えがすごい覚えるんだとかね
この子はみんなの面倒見るんだとかね
この子はすごい責任感を持ってるんだとか
そのその能力を見ると
先生にとってはものすごく楽しいんです
そこでクラスで何か何かやってる場合は
その時はもう喋らなくちゃいけない場合はみんなの代表と
それで言葉上手な子はあなたこれやりなさい
みんなの前で歌わなくちゃいけない
あなたは歌ってくださいと
全部先生やる必要ないんだから
それで舞台の裏で待っていて
子供がしっかりと歌っちゃうとものすごい気持ちいいもんなんです
あれは だからこの そういう向こうは弁論大会とかいろいろありますけど
インド文化だから結構口うるさい文化だからね
ですから そういうところに一人の子を選んで出しちゃうと
出したところで やっぱり何か売られる私たちもかなり真剣なんですよ
そこで上手にやっちゃうと
もう楽しいというと もうものすごい楽しい幸福なんですね
だから全部私がやらなくちゃ
私がやらなくちゃというのは
それはものすごい精神的な病気なんです
俺が俺がっていう感じで
だから自分やらなくてもいいんです
自分の頭が悪くても 別にどうってことない
頭の人々いっぱいいるんだから
それは喜んでもうあなた頭いいんだからこれやってくれませんかとかね
そうすると幸福っていうのはみんなに行き渡る
だからこの幸福になる道がこの花の先にあるのに
遠く遠く この月の上で見つかろうとする
向こうに空の上 星の方に行けば幸福だろうと
永久的に不幸なんです
そういうこと 今ここに自分の足元にあるものなんです
ですから 仏教は徹底的にこのカルナムディタということを育ててみろと
育ててみると すぐその場で即座に幸福になるんだと
ムディタは喜という漢字書きますけど
それは他人の幸福 才能を見て自分が喜ぶことなんです
で その 2つはその感情が生まれる時
先心所に生まれる そこは瞑想だから瞑想する時でも生まれる場合があります
ですから色界心にも生まれます
色界心の場合は  5番目の禅定の心には生まれません
ですから  1 2  3 4の禅定の心に生まれます
ということは 4つ掛ける3だから12ですね
12の先心にと普通の欲界禅定心にも生まれるんです
で 出世間心には生まれません
悟る時は生まれません
悟りの世界と関係ないんです
これは有情のこと 気になることだから
悟る場合は有情じゃなくて
現象 法を無常であることは智慧で体験することだから関係ないんです
でも 悟った人が悟ってから人のことを気になると生まれるんです
ただ お釈迦様は自分の弟子たちがもう瞑想して悟ったら大変喜ぶんです
その人に限って ああ あるいは私の子やと平気で言うんですね
別に子供ではないんだけど
お釈迦様は自分の子という言葉を使うんです
私の子っていうのは弟子という意味でね
あれは私の弟子だと あれすごい喜んで言うんですよ
だから普通の父親とその点ではそんなに変わりがないんです
お釈迦様 お釈迦様悟ったんだからって
なんかいい感情でもうなんかという感じじゃなくて
もう誰かが一生懸命頑張って悟ったら
もう父親と同じく喜びを感じる
でもそれは遊喜捨心というんですね
悟っているんだから ただその感情あるだけで
それ以上結果がない 以後全くないんだから
カルマ的な結果はないんだけど
喜びの心は生まれる そこで誰かが瞑想ができなくても悩んだりしたりすると
何とかしなくちゃと 助けてあげなくちゃと思ったりする
その時はカルナが生まれる
誰かが成功するとムディタが生まれてくる
ですから悟る時は生まれませんだけど
悟ってからは生まれるんです
なんで 5番目の禅定に生まれないかというと
5番目の禅定ではもうほとんど感情を抑えているんです
捨しかないんです 喜びももうもうそんな放っておけない感情も全部なし
ただ捨の感情 平安な感情だけですから
ないんです だからこの慈悲の慈しみの瞑想をすると
第1禅定とかとか決まってるんです
で 4までいくでしょうね
で 喜という喜びの瞑想をしたら
第4禅定まではいけるんです
だから慈悲喜捨の瞑想するとサマーディ瞑想でサマーディが生まれるんです
第1番目  2番目  3番目
4番目までは その感情を抑えて捨の瞑想すると
5番まで禅定が進む  5番以上は禅定はないんです
ありえない  [背景声]そこで最後の先進者はパンニャー
知恵 最後の先進者はパンニャーと言うんですね
知恵 それは仏教の解釈だから
パンニャーは特別なカテゴリーに入れて扱っているんです
知恵というのは 私たち言っている知恵とはものすごい違うことに
仏教で知恵とパンニャーと言うんです
でも 即的な知恵も扱ってはいるんです
例えば嘘はいけないという思う理解していることもパンニャーなんですね
嘘を言うのは人を騙すため
騙すためっていうのは
それはエゴがあって 人を騙して自分が何かやりたいから嘘を言ったりする
自分やった悪いことを隠そうと思って嘘を言ったりする
それはもうけしからん
絶対だ 立派な生き方ではないと理解することもパンニャーなんですけど
そういうところからどんどん成長して
人を悪くしてはいけない
さらに心を遠いさせなくちゃいけない
心の煩悩は全部なくさなくちゃいけないということもパンニャーなんです
それで そういうことではなくて
すべての存在はどういうものかと
心ってどういうものか
色はルーパは物質はどういうものかと
一切の存在の本当のあり方を理解することは本当のパンニャーなんです
それは現代ヨーロッパ的なヒンドゥー教的な宗教から言えば
神を理解することはパンニャーなんです
で 神というのは存在そのものだから
ですからこのそこでやっぱりすべては無常であると
苦であると 無我であるという
どちらか理解するんですね
一切は苦である 何もとらわれるものはないんだと
あるいは空であると 幻想であったと
存在自体は私も他も すべては単なる幻化の幻想であったと
心も幻想であったというふうなことは
体験することは本当のパンニャーなんです
神を知ると言ったっても
知る神がなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 一切を知るということになっちゃうんですね
一切を知ると言ったって
一切というのはもう単なる無常たるもので
流れであって生滅変化しているもので
実体はないということはわかるんです
そこはもう文学的なんですけど
この私今は文学的な言葉でね
神を知るということは単に
文学的な用語で使ってるだけであって
何の意味もないんですけど
大乗でも文学的な用語で言ってるんですね
一切衆生を救わんと思わない限りは菩薩にはならないんだと
そこで一切衆生があると思ったら
あいつまた菩薩ではないんだと
両方まとめて言ってるんですね
それをパンニャーのことを言ってるんです
パンニャーにも大乗的な菩薩の信仰を入れて
仏教も取り入れて 菩薩信仰も取り入れてという両方なんですけど
ですから矛盾といえば矛盾ですけどね
菩薩信仰を作ったこと自体は解脱を否定したことですけどね
いわゆるこのカルマですか
菩薩の場合はね カルマに重点を置いちゃったんですね
カルマに重点を置くためには
衆生がいなきゃね 困ってる
苦しんでる衆生がいなきゃ
衆生を救いたいという気持ちが生まれないんですね
そこで衆生を救う世界と智慧を発見する世界
またちょっと違うんですね
そこら辺わかってないんですね
わかってないんだから
この初期仏教からもう散々攻撃されちゃった
大乗仏教は追い出されたんだから
敗れちゃったんだからね
勝ったわけないんだよ
どこでも だから日本よりも中国よりもティベットよりも先に大乗仏教はスリランカに入ったんだから
入って間もないうちにもう散々やられちゃって
もう逃げちゃったんです
もう二度と入らなくなっちゃったんです
ですから このむちゃくちゃではないかと
あんたが言ってることがわかってないんではないか
そこでこのやられたことは知ってるんです
お釈迦様の教えとは成り立たないんだと
自分たちの立場では だからそこでいろいろごまかしをしちゃう
一つのごまかしっていうのは悟ってから戻るんだと
それこそバカバカらしくて
こいつら本当に頭があるかと
悟るってわかるんだと
悟ってからどうやって戻れるんですか
エネルギーが消したと
例えば炎を消したと また同じ炎に戻ってく
冗談じゃない 他の炎だったらもう燃えるかもしれませんだけど
全くわかってないんです
やっぱり我ですね 一旦悟ってもまた戻るんだと
衆生を救うためにと そういうのはもう単なる屁理屈だらけで
もう だからインド文化では成り立たない
中国 日本だけですね 論理的なこのアーリ人ですか
その民族の世界ではもう成り立たない
ですからヨーロッパでもやっぱり初期仏教は人気があって
知識人の中ではね 大乗仏教やってる人はいますけどね
でも成り立たないんですね
あんまりにも矛盾で ですから菩薩
菩薩を肯定しちゃうと
菩薩行は決して初期仏教でもテーラワーダでも否定してないんです
それは素晴らしいんだと
それはもう何の問題もないんだけど
菩薩とは修行中なんですね
その人は修行の その人の修行の一部が人を救うことなんです
でも完全に救うためには自分が悟った悟らなくちゃいけないんですね
だから人助けなんですね
人助けすることによって自分のエゴが消えちゃうんですね
エゴがあると人助けできない
そこでもう強引にでも嫌々ででも人を助けてあげる
その分はエゴが弱くなる
またそれはいいことだと思って
またまた次から次へとやると
それは完成したところで菩薩行は完成するんです
そこでエゴが完成 エゴをなくすプロセスが完成しているんです
そこで和素伽那瞑想に悟るんですね
ですから 菩薩行っていうのはテーラワーダにおいては確実に必要なことなんです
決して否定できない だからパーラミターという言葉を使って
もう誰でもパーラミターが完成していないと
いくらヴィパッサナーなんかそんなごまかしやったっても悟れないんだと
パーラミターっていうのは 10
パーラミターあります
10種類ありますから
ダーマン シーラン ネッカンマン
パンティサッチャ ウペッカ
ディッターガメッという
大乗仏教では 6つしかないんですけど
だからその点見たっても菩薩行だけすごいと
だから我々はあなた方は小乗仏教だと言いながら
我々はパーラミタ10種類を完成しているのに
こっちは6つだけなの
それも口先だけ 行動はなしと
よく言うんです で この間もあった比丘に
その辺どう別に仏教の人じゃないんだからしょうがないんだけどね
この小乗仏教はあだこだとか
大乗仏教だとか言って
ちょっと待ってください
あんた大乗仏教ってどういう意味ですか？まあ大乗仏教ではみんなのために行動して
そういう人々を救うということをやっている
小乗仏教は小乗仏教が自分だけのことを考えている
そうか そう言ってきた
それだったらあなた方は小乗仏教で
我々こそ本物の大乗仏教だと言った
それだったらあなた方は小乗で自分のことしか考えてないんだ
人を救う助けとまるっきりしていないではないか
あなた方の仏教は何ですか？あなた方小乗という仏教の国に行ってみてくださいと
在家も出家も 子供たちも老人たちもみんな一緒になって行動しているではないか
ですから ということで
この本当のところは我々こそ大乗仏教なんです
日本にあるのはもう仏教ではなくて
あれは邪教ですね お釈迦様の言葉をただ盗んでいるだけでね
例えば日蓮聖人が自分がブッダだよと言っているんだそうですけど
私知りませんけど 創価学会とかそういうグループがそう言ってるんですけど
日蓮がブッダだったら自分で説法しなさいと私は言いたいんだけど
日蓮何を言ったんですか？なんでインドで作った題目を南無妙法蓮華経ってそれも読まない
それだけやってるんです
それは宇宙のマンダラだ
言うんです ですからもうあれ
ブッダを拝んでいた人々をそこをやめてもらって
俺を拝みなさいということでしょう
わかりやすく言えば ずっと伝統的に拝んでた仏壇を壊しちゃって
俺の仏壇を作れということだから
だからそういうのは文化だから尊敬は私もしますけど
宗教的な評価する場合はもう若干変わらないんです
まあそんなこと悪口はどうでもいいんだけど
で パンニャーというのはやっぱりこの全ての存在
全ての現象 存在そのものどういうものかと完全に把握することであって
それで把握したところで
結果は無常という結果なんです
ですから 今更無常を知ってるよと言ったっても
それは無常を知っているわけじゃないんです
無常を知ってるんだったら
もう完全に悟ってるはずなんです
私は苦ということを知ってるよというのは
言葉は覚えているよと言った方がいいんです
苦という言葉は でも苦は知らない
だからこの存在は何ものかときちんと把握したら
引いて言えるのは無常である
苦である 空である 無我である
幻想である 幻であるということだけ
その一時的な姿であると瞬時にその姿と言えるんだと
だからこれという状態ではないんだと
それで悟りっていうのはそんなものにやられてたまるかという
もう自分が心が違う方向に向く
それが悟りだ だからマジシャンの種はバレたところで
きちんと自分が種も仕掛けも知っている
それでも感動するんだったら大馬鹿者でしょう
昨日テレビ見たんだけど
なんか例えばね ティッシュをこうやって耳に入れて
ここから出してもらうと
それをもう誰でも知ってるんですね
やり方は それで ああすごい不思議です
どうやってやるんですかと驚くと
その人はもう馬鹿もんなんですよ
種知らない場合はしょうがないんですよ
種やら仕掛けやら知らない時はまあ本当に驚いたと
知った時はもう面白くも何もないんです
ですから 存在っていうのは幻であって
幻覚であって マジシャンの影に過ぎないてるんですよ
マジシャンのしわさだと
ですから このマジシャンのしわさを発見することをヴィパッサナーなんです
ですから 知恵はそういう風に小さなところから悟りのところまで知恵があるんです
ですから 例えば嘘を言うな
人を騙すな しっかりしろ
怠けるなというのが知恵なんですよ
なぜならばそういうことだと人は幸福になりますからね
それがわずかな知恵であって
全ての存在を理解した人も一切を知って一切智者になることも知恵なんです
で こちらでは大体この全部入ってるんです
親書だから まあ我々にはわずかにはあるんです
それはとことん育てて育ててみようと
ですから 知恵には仏教ではカテゴリー入れてないんです
知恵わかってない人はそれに何とか般若
何とか何とか何とかとか言うかもしれませんだけど
そういうのはもうただのわかってないんだから言葉入れるだけ
例えばこれには小さなパンニャーと大パンニャーと最大パンニャーと超越
いくらでもいるでしょうね
言葉だから 言葉の遊びだから
それいろいろカテゴリー入れたり
カテゴリーはないんです
パンニャーはパンニャー
それだけ 知恵は知恵だけ
強弱はありますし 強烈に知ったらもう知るものも知られるものもなくなっちゃうんですね
最終的には 修行する者も修行
修行もそれも全部 もう全部幻覚で消えちゃうんですね
それは最高のパンニャー
知恵なんです 主体客体
両方消えるところで 知る人もなく
知られるものもないと
だからそこら辺言葉取られてるんですよ
ですから 菩薩が一切衆生を救おうと思うし
衆生があると思ったら
また菩薩にはないし 衆生一人も存在しない
それはこう 空只だけだと
空だけだと知ることは菩薩に必要な条件なんですね
ということは 簡単には菩薩にはなりっこないということなんです
菩薩になるためには 並ならぬ修行がまた必要になっちゃうんです
それは我々の仏教では認めているんです
いい加減にみんな菩薩と
そんなことはないんだ
菩薩になるってこと自体また大変なことなんです
だから初発と読むんですか？初菩提心ですか
ボーディチットーパーデという仏教用語ありますね
初菩提心というのは この初菩提心というのは大変なことなんです
かなりの修行の結果で
かなりの欲を捨てて そこでいくらか真理の世界に入ること
だから初菩提心のこの菩薩の段階
種別に分けてますね これは日本語わかりませんだけど
最終的にはださぼみという
それもあの結構ださぼみもこのぴったしとテーラワーダと合いませんだけど
合わないわけでもないんです
日本の方で何て言ってました？ださぼみは
お師匠さんが言ってるでしょ
大乗起信論に何たか出てきますけど
それでダサボーミサーサラという本もありますよ
大乗の時 それはもうちゃんと漢文でもありますけど
それは初期大乗仏教で生まれたワスバンドが書いたって言うんだもん
誰が書いた？ダサボーミサーサラという
菩薩の精神的な状態 十に分けて
今思い出しませんだけど
これ全部この参宿の言葉がありますけどね
そこでこの 1番目 これはこのヴィパッサナーの時だっても
この悟りの境地までいろんなレベルで考えてるんですよそこ僕は数えてないんだけど
いろいろレベルがあって
まあまあそこまで行けば戻りはしないよというレベルもありますし
で それ全部悟り以前なんですよ
例えば預流果にならなくても
かなり瞑想進んだらどこかで止まっちゃうんですね
また堕落はしないんです
でもまだまだ凡夫は凡夫なんですけど
預流果にはなってない
預流道にはなってない
でもヴィパッサナーの智慧は進んでいて
もうもう二度とは騙されない
もう物事を知っていて
無常であることは結構知っているという状態で
そういう人はみんな転生したっても
またむちゃくちゃ堕落するっていうことはないんです
ですから この精神の発達状態っていうのをサンガとは言うんです
それは当たり前ですから
人は順番に成長するんだから
で 菩薩の場合も この戻らない状態に
世俗人民というか 凡夫のレベルに戻らないところまで修行するんです
してから菩薩修行を進めていっちゃうんで
そこで 10番目に行ったらブッダになると
話があります それはまあ
大乗仏教的には明確にいろいろ解釈していますけども
でも正しい解釈だったら
やっぱり原文で見なくちゃいけない
いろんな宗派に分けてるんだから
そういう人々の解釈は全くもう当てにならないと
いい加減ですけど 昔書いた人々はそれなりの瞑想していろいろ経験があって
それに基づいてこういうラスブン・サッツァっていう本とか書いてるんです
唯識論の中でも結構瞑想して
いろいろ体験があって
それに基づいて書いてるんですから
そこら辺はもうまるっきりいい加減の嘘ということではないんです
でも矛盾は生まれるんです
菩薩行の場合は確実に
だからその矛盾はテーラワーダの世界ではきちんと解決しているのは
この覚悟を決めることはかなり智慧が必要なんですよ
輪廻は脱するぞと その覚悟を決めることは大変なことなんです
脱するぞと思っても脱できないのは自分の弱みなんですね
でも欲で遊んだり 食べて寝たり
もうよく金儲けたりするのは無意味だよとわかってはいるんです
わかったんだけど 悟れない
どこかでちょっとした心の弱みがある
でも一般の人とはその人は随分違うんです
心が 全然未練がない 世俗人民にとっては
それで自分が菩薩修行しちゃう
パーラミタを完成しようとする
お布施から始めて お布施を完成するは
戒律を守ってみるは 瞑想してみるは
それからネッカンは怨怒の実践
欲を捨てることをいろいろ試してみるわとかね
それから忍耐 忍辱 いろんな不幸なもう気に入らないいろんな出来事があっても
心は安定してする 訓練してみるは
それ全部エゴがエゴから生まれるもんなんですよ
人に悪口を言われた 殴られた
貶されたと怒るのはエゴがある時なんで
その時は私は菩薩修行するんだと
ですから 何言われても平然な心で
頑張りますという風にこのターラミタを全部完成しなくちゃいけない
それにはもう何回生まれ変わらなくちゃいけないかっていうのはもうたくさんですけどね
お釈迦様もそうでしたから
菩薩時代をずっともう何千万年も完成したんです
一つ物語を思い出したんだけど
言うんだけど お釈迦様はこの忍耐を完成したストーリーがありまして
で 菩薩の時はこの出家したんだそうです
出家して山の中に行って
暇な時に帰って また雨の時は町に来る
町に来て 王様のこの公園がありまして
その公園に入っているんです
そこで王様が遊びに行く
自分の奥さんたちと一緒に遊ぶ
遊び回って疲れて自分に気に入ってる奥さんの膝の上に頭を置いて寝てるんです
膝枕にして寝て寝たところで眠っちゃったんです
酒飲んだりいろんなことして遊んだんだから
それで他の奥さんたちがやることないんですね
やることないんだから
見たらもうこの行者を見たんです
そしたらそこに行ったんです
そこに行ってその人と色々話をする
そこでこの奥さんが一人になっちゃって
腹が立って まあどうせ女性同士だから
まあそういう必ずものすごい強烈な戦いをしてるんですよ
だからすごい悲しい世界なんですよ
この昔はね 中国でもそうでしたし
皇帝がね たくさんの女をありったけの美人たちをみんなもうそれもらっちゃうでしょ
だからもう顔もわからない
何人いるかもわからない
だから互いにね 大変地獄なんですけど
そういう生活っていうのは
そこでその女の人がすごく腹が立って
なんで自分だけここにいなくちゃいけないかと思って王様を起こしちゃうんですね
起こして起こされたんだから怒って
王様がこの人どこ行ったんですか？って言ったら
あっち行ってるんだと
そしたらさらに怒ったんですね
言っても大体っていうのは王様の奥さんと喋ってはいけないぐらいのことだからね
でも何も何もすることもできないし
この人 ものすごく怒って
お前何者なの？何やってる人なの？私はこの忍耐を修行しているんだ
何があっても平安な心でいるという忍耐を修行しているんだ
あ そうと言って 鞭でこいつを鞭で打ちなさい
で もう 1000回ぐらいもうめちゃくちゃ鞭で打った
打ったら 打つ度に皮膚が破れて血が出て血まみれになっちゃうんです
倒れて どうですか？あんた今も平安な心でいるんですか？だから何も悪いことしてない人には鞭で打たれたんだから
言ったら忍耐っていうのは皮膚にあるものではないと言うんですね
だから菩薩は修行してるんですね
今私のは打たれている
すごく痛い で それは皮膚は痛く痛いんであって
ということで もう修行してるんですね
その時は忍耐の修行 と言ったら
もうどんどんエスカレートするんですね
このいじめること そこで皮膚じゃないかと言って
もうじゃあ手を切れ 手を切断させるって言ったら
菩薩はその時も修行してたでしょうとか
手を切断されたと でも手は手であって
それはまあ心とは関係ない
それで両手切断されて
足も で 最後に鼻を切っちゃうわけです
で その度に私の忍耐は鼻にあるわけじゃないと
足にあるわけじゃないと
じゃあ王様がじゃあお前の忍耐はどこにあるんですか？とにかくその人を怒る
怒りたい 怒らす 怒り作りたいんですね
それは心にあるものだと言ったら
ものすごい力強く胸を踏んだんですね
骨折れるぐらいで そしたらもう口から血出て
もう行って帰っちゃって
まあ勝手にしろ 王様が負けて帰ったら
この大臣たちがそこには閉めて
昔 インドでは聖者やら宗教家をいじめてはいけないと
もし宗教家の腹が立ったら
いじめたら国ごとに不幸になるんだとという信仰があるんです
それは信仰だけじゃなくて
本当はそういうことなんですよ
決して心清らかな人の気持ち悪くなることしたら
その人は別に気にしませんだけど
やった人は大変なことになるんです
それはもう語りとは違いますよ
強烈なんです みんなにも関係ある人々みんなにも言っちゃえばすごい危険なことなんだから
インドでそういう人いっぱいあるんです
ですから この大臣たちが一生懸命謝って謝って
これはもう王様がやったことであって
国民がやったことじゃないんだと
ですから なんていますか
語るならば王様個人を
その人個人を語ってもいいんだけど
国民のことを許してあげてくださいとお願いするんだから
いい そんなことないんだと
王様も幸福でありますように
国民も幸福でありますようにと私は思います
それは私の修行だ 何があっても忍耐をするのは私の修行だから
私はわずかでも誰に対しても怒りはしませんと言って
その場で亡くなっちゃうんですね
それはお釈迦様ご出家の時代でお釈迦様は遠い昔ですね
過去生でどのように忍耐を修行したんですかと
だからそこは忍耐 何があっても忍耐をするのは私の修行だから
私はわずかでも誰に対しても怒りはしませんと言って
その場で亡くなっちゃうんですね
それはお釈迦様ご出家の時代でお釈迦様は遠い昔ですね
過去生でどのように忍耐を修行したんですかと
だからそこは忍耐パーラミタの完成として言ってるんですね
そこまでできれば あれまで打たれてぶたれて
足は両足も両手も鼻も切られて
耳も両耳も別々に切られて
それでも安らかな気持ちでいられるということは
相手に対してわずかにも怒らないんです
大変なことなんですね
ですから そういう風な素敵なストーリーがストーリーがいっぱいあって
このパーラミタの完成のことは入っているんです
ですから このそういう中途半端なパーラミタじゃないんですよ
例えば観音さんという人がいて
みんなの面倒見てあげたがってるんだとか
だからこちらは 10円
賽銭箱に入れて拝めばいいとかね
そんな原始的なアニミズムではないんです
仏教は 初期大乗仏教も
アニミズムではなかったんですけど
そんな観音がいるわけじゃないし
我々のわがまま聞いてくれるじゃなくて
こちらのエゴを捨てなくちゃいけないんです
例えば観音像を見たら
とりあえず仏像と言うんだから礼をするだけで何も要りませんと
という気持ちでないと
私で何かしてあげるんだけど
できるだけのことを誰にでも
私には何もしてくれなくても結構だというぐらいで
心は育てなくちゃいけない
立派な人間になるわけで
そういうのは菩薩行なんですけどね
人を助けることをね 救ってあげること
それでエゴがあると忍耐が消えちゃう
エゴがあると布施ができなくなっちゃう
エゴがあると慈悲ができなくなっちゃう
ですから パーラミタが完成する過程において
自分のエゴという感情がどんどん消えていく
でも無常であることを輪廻は良くないとか
ね 苦しみだけやって それをわかってはいるんです
輪廻にはいたくない でも悟らない
そこでもパーラミタの問題が出てくるわけです
非混の問題が出てくるわけです
まだまだパーラミタ完成足りないと徳が足らない
その徳っていうのは 自分のエゴについてどれぐらい自分がチャレンジしているかということなんです
怒ってはいけないってこと
誰でも知ってますけど
それはエゴがある限りは必ずすぐ怒ってしまうし
そういうことでこの 菩薩はやっぱり修行中という立場は我々は初期仏教では
初期仏教じゃなくてテーラワーダでは修行中であると
だからといって もう修行中でいたっても
もうどうでもいい人間ではなくて
それ相当人なんですよ
菩薩になるってことも大変な智慧必要ですから
大変な修行やら瞑想やら必要だからね
そのくらいに行くためには
でも凡夫であることはまた変わりはない
天狗にまた堕落してということでもないし
でもいつか完成したところに悟るという立場なんですね
ですから 菩薩信仰がない
じゃあそれでパンニャーというものはこういう智慧だから
専心所に生まれるんで
専心の場合はこのナーナさんと言って
地相ですか 地相心が生まれる
それからだいたいもう色界心にも無色界心にも生まれる
確実に出世間心にも生まれる
生まれないのは地不相応の心の十二だけなんですね
で 心所の説明は大体それぐらいにしましょう
またいろいろ組み合わせがありまして
[背景音]